a breathtaking scientific revolution is
taking place
biotechnology has been progressing at
stunning speed giving us the tools to
eventually gain control over biology
on the one hand solving the deadliest
diseases while also creating viruses
more dangerous than nuclear bombs able
to devastate Humanity what's going on
biotech capability
biotechnology is increasingly everywhere
the cotton in your clothes the
vegetables you eat your dog humans
manipulate living things we use bacteria
to produce insulin connect Prosthetics
directly with our brains and make
industrial enzymes to produce paper
gene therapy creates cures to previously
untreatable diseases while we're working
on food crops resistant to climate
change
our Mastery over biology has been
speeding up so much that within weeks of
the first covid-19 case the unknown
coronavirus was broken down in
Laboratories and analyzed scientists
generated a copy of its genetic material
to create a vaccine that was ready for
testing months after the pandemic began
something Unthinkable a decade ago
where is all this sudden progress coming
from
well it's complicated but in a nutshell
really expensive things got cheap and
knowledge of how to do impressive things
spread freely
the Human Genome Project starting in
1990 was the first major attempt to read
human DNA in its entirety 13 years and
three billion dollars later it was
complete by then the cost of decoding a
human genome had fallen to about 100
million dollars
today it's one hundred thousand times
cheaper costing only about a thousand
dollars how is that possible converting
DNA into computer data and then studying
it used to be a super tedious process
taking expert humans around three years
of manual work today it takes about two
weeks and is almost completely automated
biotechnology has gone from something
restricted to the best and well-funded
Laboratories staffed by the world's top
experts to something affordable enough
for hundreds of thousands of people to
casually work on what sped up the
process even more is that information in
the field is shared widely and freely
cutting-edge discoveries now take just
about a year to be copied in
Laboratories around the world a few
years for anyone with a biology
background to work out and a bit over a
decade for high school students to
experiment with them in schools imagine
that your local computer repair shop
could build a pristine iPhone 11 with
just the parts lying around and that
teenagers are asked to build a new
iPhone 5 for homework not a crappy
homemade version the real thing this is
what's going on right now in
biotechnology a true Revolution we are
adding knowledge at unprecedented rate
while things get ever faster and cheaper
to do this speed means we can expect
even more wonderful things for Humanity
life-saving treatments Miracle crops and
solutions to problems we can't even
imagine right now
but unfortunately progress Cuts both
ways what can be used for good can also
be used for bad by accident or on
purpose
what if you could build a nuclear bomb
in your backyard
for all the good biotech will do for us
in the near future it also could easily
kill many millions of people in the
worst case hundreds of millions worse
than any nuclear bomb
the world just witnessed how fast the
novel coronavirus spread we still don't
know for sure if it came from nature or
was the result of an accidental leak
from a lab working with coronaviruses
that's still subject to Scientific
debate in the end at least seven million
people died and this was still a
relatively mild virus that didn't cause
serious disease in most of those
infected but that might change in the
future wherever the last pandemic came
from the next one might very well be our
own fault in a sense many things going
on in biotechnology could lead to this
most of all how easy it is to work with
dangerous viruses
thousands of scientists can simply order
the genetic data of infectious virus
samples online to experiment with them
assembling these into an artificial
virus in 2023 costs about as much as a
new car including all the lab equipment
at the same time other scientists are
trying to find viruses that hide in
nature like in Wild bats or monkeys
there are probably plenty of potentially
deadly pandemics out there
virus Hunters take samples back to the
lab to learn whether the newly
discovered viruses are likely to spread
in humans and catalog the danger when a
biologist discovers a new virus they
usually publish its genetic data to the
public journals are eager to share
descriptions of potentially dangerous
viruses other labs go further and make
viruses more dangerous
they combine and mutate different
viruses to understand which mutations
make them more likely to spread between
humans or make them deadlier than their
original forms and again these results
are shared freely all while synthetic
DNA and equipment to rebuild these
viruses are sold online to anyone
without any or very little tracking
as the tools of biotechnology get ever
cheaper and easy to use and the data on
dangerous viruses keeps multiplying it's
only a matter of time before a
well-meaning scientist shares blueprints
for the equivalent nuclear bomb of
viruses a superbug that will cause
millions of deaths and someone uses it
maybe because they have bad intentions
maybe because they're irresponsible or
sloppy we're creating an environment in
which it's increasingly easy for anyone
to create a weaponized virus in their
backyard this is scary the world will be
plunged into an unending crisis as new
pandemics pop up year after year or all
at once killing large parts of the
world's population doing unimaginable
damage to civilization as a whole and
possibly undoing centuries of progress
what can we do turns out a lot it's not
the first time we've faced a challenge
like this and we are not helpless think
of nuclear technology something
extremely powerful and dangerous with
huge upsides and downsides nuclear
energy was born from weapon programs so
its creators were always aware of the
potential for their knowledge to be
abused from the very beginning it was
clear that knowledge in this field and
access to the technology needed to be
handled with utmost care so a lot of
effort has gone into making sure no
radioactive material disappears from
site or that countries don't try to hide
weapons development behind energy
programs
the result hasn't been perfect but
considering the 411 nuclear power
stations running today we've been very
successful likewise no researcher would
think to share data on how to turn
common laboratory equipment into
bomb-making machines on the internet
there's no reason we couldn't handle the
really dangerous aspects of
biotechnology in a similar way
experts have come up with three sort of
bullet points
first we need to delay the next deadly
pandemic by getting a grip on how we
treat dangerous viruses their genetic
data should be treated as an info Hazard
information that poses a danger to
society if it's shared without care in
other words not just anyone should be
able to order dangerous DNA online and
if you do you should be tracked so it
becomes much harder for the wrong people
to access the really spicy stuff
the next step is detecting the danger by
becoming aware which viruses are present
Among Us and are spreading explosively
between humans
this could be as easy as having labs in
population centers maintain virus
detectors that monitor what's going on
in the micro world
we suddenly see certain microorganisms
show up a lot in a short time we can
react quickly and start countermeasures
which is the final step destroy
we basically need to build a machine
that's ready to destroy any pandemic
threat before it has a chance to take
over we can do this with new tools that
are being developed right now like Nano
filters that pull dangers out of the air
we breathe or specialized UV lamps that
just kill any virus before it has a
chance to jump from person to person and
of course we need to get better at
getting new vaccines faster than ever
before in history if we do these three
things the chances are really good that
we can avoid a catastrophic pandemic in
the future
biotechnology like any exciting and
Powerful technology is neither
inherently good or bad
it has the potential to be both in
breathtaking ways we have the chance to
have a future where we get to truly
control biology our biology the biology
of the plants and animals around us and
the biology of the micro world
so let's use it to create a future where
we triumph over pandemics and diseases
for good
this video was supported by open
philanthropy if you want to help and
want to have a high impact on the world
check out the Biore risk career guide
from 80 000 hours a non-profit
organization that helps people find
careers that can tackle some of
Humanity's greatest problems in the most
efficient way
we put a link and further reading in the
description and sources aside from buyer
risk there are more guides to check out
too
let's tell you about one of the most
embarrassing moments in quartz goes out
history it's a pretty great story a few
years ago we posted an image of a fake
evolutionary tree on social media just
to post something nice without thinking
about it but we messed with the wrong
verbs immediately we got thousands of
messages from you telling us how wrong
it was unscientific bad we
underestimated that you take everything
that we put out into the world seriously
and you set high standards for our
research and fact-checking process this
hurt a lot we wanted to be better than
that so we deleted it and contacted
experts and spent hundreds of hours on
research and illustration and developed
a new visualization of the relationships
between species that didn't exist before
a map of evolution you can use to figure
out how closely you're related to a
flying lemur expert approved we were
extremely proud of the result and since
we'd spent so much time on it we turned
it into a poster and from that a new
vision was born we wanted to become the
best infographic and science poster shop
in the world today we've designed almost
100 posters and sold over half a million
gobbies every single one made with love
care and lots of attention to detail all
because you guys challenged us thank you
so much for that and for supporting our
weird ideas and our sometimes weird
merch
because of you we can continue to
release our videos for free for everyone
and drop hundreds of hours into New
Concepts to spark curiosity in people
all around the world thank you so so
much for being part of our vision we
literally couldn't do it without you
[Music]
wait
foreign